JEFF CARLONI: Good afternoon.
Thanks for coming
to our discussion
about rethinking
your waste today.
I hope you find it
informative and fun.
My name is Jeff Carloni.
I'm a resource and materials
management consultant here
at Google with a goal of helping
Google achieve a zero waste
future.
That's my role here.
I'm honored to be joined
by our three panelists here
who have come to talk about
their personal journeys
to reducing waste
in their lives.
My hope is that from
the discussion today,
you can all take away
one or two things that
can help you to reduce your
waste in your own world,
and we'll discuss some
impacts that waste
has on human health
and the environment
and topics like that.
The format today is
meant to be interactive,
so I'm going to kind
of open up and ask
you each a few questions.
And then once they get
bored of me talking,
I'll ask you guys to ask some
questions if you have any,
so we'll go with that.
So with that, I'll go ahead
and introduce our panelists.
To my right, we have
Michael O'Heaney.
He's the executive director of
Story of Stuff Has anyone seen
the videos on "Story of Stuff?"
OK, cool.
Yeah, so he's behind the
scenes running those things.
To plagiarize from your website,
"We have a problem with stuff.
We use too much, too
much of it is toxic,
and we don't share it
very well, but that's not
the way things have to be.
Together we can build a society
based on better, not more;
sharing, not selfishness;
and community, not division.
The Story of Stuff
Project's journey
began with a 20-minute online
movie called "Story of Stuff"
about the way we make,
use, and throw away
all the stuff in our lives.
So that was five years
ago and 40 million
views they've had now
on all their videos.
They're a community
of more than a million
change-makers worldwide,
of which I am one.
I signed up.
And they're working to
build a healthy community
and a just planet.
So Michael brings over
15 years of experience
as an advocate
fundraiser and consultant
in his role as
executive director.
Prior to joining
Story of Stuff, he
developed fundraising and
communication strategies
for environmental, civil
rights, and reproductive justice
and media reform organizations
as a principal of Channing Way
Consulting.
He also served as a
development director
for two San Francisco
Bay Area advocacy
organizations, Global Exchange
and Pacific Environment.
Welcome, Michael.
MICHAEL O'HEANEY: Thank you.
Thank you.
JEFF CARLONI: To his
right, we have Bea Johnson,
who some of you saw give an
authors talk at Google just
an hour ago in this very room.
Bea lives a waste-free life
with her family since 2008.
This jar here actually
represents her entire waste
for her whole family for 2014.
She's an author of
the bestseller book
called "Zero Waste Home," which
I recommend you pick up a copy.
She's a zero waste
lifestyle expert,
so she'll be a
great person to hear
some tips on for
your personal lives
and what you can do to simply
reduce your waste streams.
She'll talk about how living
waste-free can not only
be stylish, but lead to
significant health benefits
and reduce cost savings and
just improve your general lives,
in general.
She was a grand prize
winner of Green Award.
She's invited to speak at
events like this all the time.
She's told me this-- today
she's done over 100 probably,
talks like this at
universities and conferences
throughout the world.
She's going to Brazil in a
month to talk more about it.
BEA JOHNSON: It's nothing new.
JEFF CARLONI: It's
not, I'm ad-libbing.
It's crazy.
MICHAEL O'HEANEY: The
embargo just got broken.
JEFF CARLONI: I'll just
end with "The New York
Times" called her the "Priestess
of waste-free living."
I like that title.
She's a spokesperson for zero
waste lifestyle, clearly.
And then so welcome, Bea.
BEA JOHNSON: Thank you.
JEFF CARLONI: To her right, we
have Bettina, Bettina Limaco.
Am I saying that right?
BETTINA LIMACO: Yes.
JEFF CARLONI: She's
the owner of Green11.
So Green11 is a refill
store in San Francisco.
They have two locations
in San Francisco
and a partner
location in San Mateo.
Essentially their claim is
refill is the new recycle.
So if you go to their store,
expect to bring your own jars
and bring your own
bags and refill.
Everything's bulk packaging.
Her goals are to challenge
the standards of consumerism
by modeling and promoting the
idea of refill, not landfill,
and make sustainable living
attainable by offering
eco-conscious products
for refilling.
Her store's been featured
on SBC and "SF Magazine's"
"Best of the Bay" series.
I certainly hope someday it'll
be a nationwide phenomenon
because we all could live
better lives with less waste.
So welcome, Bettina.
BETTINA LIMACO: Thanks.
JEFF CARLONI: All
right, I'll kind of
start off by asking, I'll
start with you Michael,
since you're to my right.
Give us a higher
level overview, how
are we doing as a nation
in terms of waste?
What are some of the challenges
that you see in this industry?
MICHAEL O'HEANEY: Terrible
in many ways, better
in a lot of ways,
and some folks,
both on an individual level,
company level, community level,
are doing better than others.
So I think the
sort of core issue
here for us as a
country is we produce
far more waste than
our population density
in the world.
So part of that is our
high level of consumption,
but it is also over the
last 50 years the move
to a much more sort of
disposable culture--
the emergence of
things like fast food
wrappers and packaging, bottled
water is a thing that we talk
about quite a bit, a
whole series of sort
of "convenience items"
that have been created.
There is also just the
growth in packaging and sort
of all of these kinds of
things wrapped together make
for a quite wasteful society.
As I mentioned, though,
there are places that
are doing some incredible work.
San Francisco and other cities
that are doing zero waste
work at the municipal
level to make sure
that they're diverting more
of their waste from landfills
either by recycling
or composting.
Municipal compost
programs are fantastic.
And then there are companies.
I think there's probably not
a company in the United States
now that doesn't have some
sort of a sustainability plan
that either their employees
at work, making sure
that they are having less
impact on the earth, but then
also companies figuring out
how to use renewable energy,
how to create zero
waste campuses, just how
to operate in a way that
takes more care of the planet.
JEFF CARLONI: So what's
the problem with waste?
What are the human
health impacts?
What relationship are there
between waste and greenhouse
gases and things like that?
MICHAEL O'HEANEY: I was going to
say, how much time do we have?
JEFF CARLONI: Not that much.
MICHAEL O'HEANEY: So
waste is a big problem.
We'll take one example.
In terms of human health, we've
been doing quite a bit of work
recently.
We were talking
about on microbeads,
which are the little
plastic beads that are
used in personal care products.
Companies have
basically replaced
sort of organic materials
in facial cleansers and body
scrubs and even toothpaste
with microplastics.
Those microplastics wash
through water treatment
into the environment.
They are the size of fish food.
Fish eat them.
We've done research
for the last couple
of years that shows
fish are actually
eating these microplastics
in the environment.
Part of the problem
is plastics are fatty,
so they attract the toxins
in the water around them.
Fish eat them.
That magnifies up
the food chain.
So I think many of us
who grew up with an idea
that waste goes away
somewhere, and I think
one of the big challenges we
have is to get over this idea
that there really is no "away."
We live on this
floating blue ball
bumping around the universe
and there is only one planet.
Unless someone figures out a
way to colonize another one,
we've got to be here.
And so from impacts on food
to fence line communities who
live along dumps
or incinerators,
the ways that we deal
with waste have impacts.
And then I think just
generally, societally,
really the sort of throwaway
culture, the sort of fast food,
run through products,
toss products, the fact
that things aren't made
to last the way they used
to be, I think that
actually says something
about our society and is
a reflection of the way
that we live, and it's
not a positive reflection.
So I think there's impacts
across the spectrum.
JEFF CARLONI: Great, thank you.
And kind of to that point, you
just kind of touched on this,
but our society I feel is very
much built on the principle
that more is better-- more
growth, more money, more stuff,
GDP always has to be rising.
That equals a better life
for our families, right?
But this quest for more
often leads many of us
to the keeping up with the
Joneses kind of mentality,
and I guess my question for
Bea is how do you tell people
to keep up with the Johnsons?
What's your way?
How can you change the
paradigm from keeping up
with the Joneses to keeping
up with the Johnsons?
BEA JOHNSON: I can't tell
anyone how to live their lives.
I think it's up to everyone
to live the way they want.
All I can do from my point of
view is to live by example.
I think we've been
able to show even
just in our immediate
friendships and family
and even now
throughout the world
that by living simply
and by wasting less,
we're actually
able to live more.
Today by thanks to
wasting less, we've
been able to turn
our life from instead
of being based on stuff, today
it's based on experiences.
It's made our life
so much richer.
It's allowed us to create
memories to last a lifetime,
and memories last so
much longer than stuff.
Yeah, definitely.
She was here earlier
doing a talk, like I said,
and she had some great slides
show all her vacations.
And I'm going on vacation
tomorrow, by the way,
so I was very
excited to see that.
And it's true because a lot of
times, our stuff kind of ends
up owning us.
You have to maintain it
and clean it constantly.
And the less you have, the
more you can go out and live.
BEA JOHNSON: Well, if
you don't buy packaging,
if you buy only
what you need, then
you can invest your money
into things that matter
instead of spending-- every
time you buy packaging
or a disposable product, it's
literally investing your money
into the landfill,
investing your money into
or basically throwing
your money out the window.
Once you regain that
power and you decide,
no, I'm not throwing my
money out the window,
then you can put your
money into something
that creates memories.
Invest your money
into experiences.
JEFF CARLONI: What would you say
to those people that have kids?
Like you have two kids,
and I know for me,
it's sometimes hard to
get other people on board.
Do they think you were
crazy the first day
you started doing this,
or how did they feel
about the whole zero waste?
BEA JOHNSON: I have teenagers.
They still think I'm crazy.
There is nothing I
can do about that.
And I can't even
predict the future.
I can't tell whether
my kids will do
zero waste when they grow up.
It's up to them to find the
life that they want to live,
but I feel comfortable
as a mother knowing
that I am giving them the tools
to live a waste-free lifestyle
if they choose to do it later.
I think whatever, doesn't
matter how we're raised,
I think the way-- or I should
say the way we're were raised
is the way we accept things.
I think my kids are
being raised waste-free,
but to them, it's the norm.
And even if they choose
to rebel against it,
I know that they will return
back to basics and to what
they've been taught.
I think they've been able
to show their friends
that our lifestyle is actually
quite cool because they've
been able to do things that
their friends would love
to do, and their friends
are telling their parents,
why can't we do
like the Johnsons?
Why can't we do
this and do that?
But it's just that we're able
to do these things because we're
not wasting.
That's where sometimes
the connection is missed.
JEFF CARLONI: That's where
I'll trying to keep up
with the Johnsons, very good.
Great, thank you.
Bettina, this
question's for you.
What are some challenges of
operating a refill-only store?
Do you have customers, people
coming and going, what do I do?
Tell me some examples.
BETTINA LIMACO: Yeah, actually
they do that all the time.
They actually come in, and
many people that sort of just
walk by our store have
lived in the neighborhoods
where we operate and really
have no idea what we do.
So they think we're
a chemical store
and then they finally make
it in after five years
and come in and ask
exactly what we do.
And then we describe
the concept, which
is we operate a refill shop.
So we encourage you to
bring in your own container,
to buy everyday products you
need like laundry, shampoo
and conditioner, and dish
soap and anything that
comes in a plastic
packaging, and we just
refill the bottles for you for
everyday products you need.
I think one of the
biggest challenges of that
is really a change in behavior.
So it takes a long
time for people
to sort of remember to bring
in a bottle and to refill it.
So a lot of times, we
get people buying bottles
in the store to start,
and then once they've
seen the effect of throwing
less bottles in the blue bin,
then I think it becomes
a very big habit.
So within my initially
only refill laundry,
but once they've
refilled laundry,
then they start to
think, oh, wait a minute,
can I refill the dish soap?
I wonder if they
have this product.
And so our offerings
of refill products
have actually increased
over time, so now
we actually have
things like toothpaste
that we refill and
deodorant, and you
see more and more companies
kind of rethinking
the way they distribute products
so that it's a refill idea.
JEFF CARLONI: And the
company's called Green11
and you told me earlier that
was because initially there
was 11 product offerings.
How many products are there now?
BETTINA LIMACO: I
don't actually know.
It's probably double
that, so like toothpaste
is one of the most recent
additions we've had,
and then recently we have
SPF, face and body SPF.
BEA JOHNSON: You do?
Yes!
BETTINA LIMACO: Yeah.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
And also now you can
change your packaging.
You can now have
unmarked packaging.
You can use glass
and mason jars.
We see them come
through the store.
And so--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
BETTINA LIMACO:
Whatever you have.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BETTINA LIMACO: That's
right, that's right.
And we sell everything
by the weighted ounce.
So if you brought in a giant
bottle, a glass bottle,
we'd weigh it out and
then we'd just refill it,
so you pay for the product
that you actually need.
And I don't know if
many of you know,
but for every dollar you spend
on anything in the store,
probably like let's say a dish
soap, it's probably $0.20,
the cost of the dish.
And everything else is the cost
of supply chain distribution.
So packaging, the
amount of time spent
on a label and what
shade of yellow that
should be is enormous, and
so it's a non-value add cost.
JEFF CARLONI: So what about the
requirements on the back end?
So you get products
in, I assume, in bulk.
How do you kind of hold your
suppliers to the same standards
that you're giving
to your customers?
BETTINA LIMACO: That's
actually a great question
because the average person
that refills-- or we have
some customers in our store
that refill because we're just
plain cheaper for really
high-end products,
and they don't think
past what we do.
So when you refill
from Green11, it's
a true closed-loop distribution.
So we order all of our
laundry in 55-gallon drums,
and all of our dish soap
and most of our cleaners
come in concentrate
and we mix it ourselves
at our distribution center.
And our 55-gallon jugs that
we receive in a distribution
center are repartnered with a
company in central California
who comes and collects
all those 55-gallon drums
and rebreaks them down
into little blue pellets
that can be reblown into
new 55-gallon drums.
So it's a true
closed-loop distribution.
There isn't any waste.
JEFF CARLONI: So did
those suppliers already
have that kind of
process, or did
you kind of have to force
them to change the process
to have that?
BETTINA LIMACO: No, they already
produced in 55-gallon drums.
JEFF CARLONI: Cool,
so it wouldn't
be so difficult for
other entrepreneurs
to potentially set
up a similar store?
BETTINA LIMACO: That's right.
JEFF CARLONI: Anywhere
else in the country?
BETTINA LIMACO:
That's right, and we
get reached out from
everywhere, actually--
not just around the country,
but everywhere-- for help
to open up a refill shop
in their neck of the woods,
and we're very happy
to help people do that.
We think there's room
for this business,
and we actually need
people to be inspired by it
and open refill
shops everywhere.
And we've done it, so we
have a couple of partners
in Wisconsin, for example.
JEFF CARLONI: Great.
Franchising opportunity, great.
OK, we'll come back
to you, Michael.
Talk about manufactured demand,
if you could for a second,
and specifically,
I'm curious the kind
of the rise over
the last I don't
know 15, 20 years of the
single-use water bottle
because I know we talk
about that a lot here.
How have we been so convinced
that water-bottle water
is healthier and more
convenient for us
when really in
actuality, it costs more,
it's probably not as
healthy, and it has
all the environmental impacts?
MICHAEL O'HEANEY: Well,
one, I would encourage
people to watch "The
Story of Bottled Water"
if you haven't seen or
already, which basically tells
the story of bottled
water, but really tells
the story of
manufactured demand.
So manufactured
demand in essence is,
how do you convince
people to buy something
like bottled water that
they can already get
virtually free from the tap?
Bottled water costs
many times what
it would cost you
just to go and fill up
your glass with tap water.
So a couple of things.
One, the environmental movement,
I think-- one of the reasons
we got involved in
environmental communications
is the environmental
movement did
a very good job over
the last 30 years
for some very good
reasons of scaring people,
of convincing people that there
was danger in their water,
that there was
danger in the soil,
that there's danger lurking
around every corner.
And the bottled water industry,
which is a quite new industry.
I know bottled water didn't
exist when I was a kid,
and I'm not that old.
It existed, but it
was like Perrier.
It was this sort of odd thing
that wealthy people used.
And we were talking earlier.
When I was a kid, I don't
remember taking water
to ball games, or we've
kind of become very obsessed
with having water
on us at all times.
But basically, the
bottled water industry
went out and did a very good
job of convincing people
through advertising,
through marketing
that their water was unsafe.
And so we've done now over
the last decade quite a number
of side-by-side
taste tests, we've
done reviews of water safety.
For most Americans, their
tap water is quite safe.
There's no problem with it.
There are certainly
communities where
there are more issues
with the water that
comes out of the tap.
Every time we talk
about this issue,
we get people talking
about water fluoridation,
for instance.
That's something that
concerns a lot of people.
But generally
speaking, the water
that comes out of the tap
in homes and businesses
around the United
States is quite safe.
The bottled water industry at
some level has now shifted,
and their argument now, which I
think is actually quite smart,
is around sort of choice,
is around giving people
a choice between a
sugar-sweetened beverage
like a soda or a fruit
juice, and water,
which is a healthier choice.
So they've sort of shifted their
marketing from fear tactics
around safety of water,
what comes out of your tap,
to bottled water being the sort
of safer choice for people who
are health-conscious and
are concerned about things
like weight gain and diabetes
and all the kinds of things
that come with
drinking too much soda.
So, yeah, they've
done an incredible job
of convincing people that
they needed this product.
Now, some of it also was making
it the sort of elegant choice.
It was around convenience
and those kinds of things.
But fundamentally, when you
ask most people why they're
drinking it, it's
either convenience
or some sort of a fear
about their own water.
What we say to folks is if
you are actually concerned
about what's coming
out of your tap,
it is much cheaper and
more cost-effective
and more
environmentally friendly
just use a filter on your tap.
You can get filters
for taps now or use
a Brita or something like that.
But bottled water, unless
it's like an emergency kind
of situation-- this is the
other argument they use,
but what about
natural disasters?--
bottled water is just
something that people really
don't for the large part need.
JEFF CARLONI: So
what role should us
trying to individually
change people's behavior
versus government
regulation, what sort of mix
do you see kind of working
for things like that?
MICHAEL O'HEANEY: So I
think a couple of-- well,
I think around bottled water,
the most important thing,
businesses, communities--
so there's a great story.
A university-- it was
University of Florida
or Florida State,
one or the other,
built a new stadium within them.
I think it was about
10, 12 years ago.
And Coke, I think, was the
water distributor, basically
convinced the stadium
builders that they
didn't need many water
fountains because we're going
to be selling bottled water.
So they have the first game.
It was an opening football game.
It was like a 98-degree
day or something like that,
and no one wanted to buy
a $4 bottle of water.
And so they had all
of these health issues
and basically the city
went to them and said,
you've got to figure out
how to get more water in.
So the things that businesses,
communities, folks can do
is one, reinvest in
water infrastructure.
We are underinvesting
in water infrastructure
in a massive way.
Businesses like
Google and others--
super important,
if people really
feel the need for filtered
water, to put refill stations.
SFO, the airport now, has them.
A lot of the airports
have them now.
You can't carry water
through the security, anyway,
but you can carry a
refillable container,
and now they have I think they
call them "hydration stations."
City of San Francisco
passed an ordinance
that basically barred
sales of bottled water
on city property-- so festivals
and those kinds of things.
But part of that
law was you actually
have to have sufficient
water infrastructure
for those events.
If you're going to take
away the bottled water,
you've got to have
the ability for people
to actually get water, as well.
So really water infrastructure
and the ability of people
to get the water that they want
so that they're not using soda
if they don't want to is the
most important thing, I think.
JEFF CARLONI: Great, thank you.
I'll kind of take a break here.
Does anyone have a question
burning in their mind
before I continue asking
my list of questions?
Yes, Jamie?
JAMIE: So I think it's
really interesting
to see that, Michael, we've
got this big landscape of waste
and the story of stuff.
And then Bea, we
have a lifestyle,
your own personal lifestyle
story, and then all the way
down to Bettina, who's able to
do at this kind of micro level.
Can the two ladies
talk about how
to sort of transition
away from a life of stuff
to a life of less stuff,
because I always feel really
guilty having my
stuff, but I don't
know if I know the right
way to transition away.
BEA JOHNSON: I
give a lot of tips
in the book on how to do that.
It obviously to
me, I think the way
I started decluttering
is I was put
in a situation where we moved
from one area into another.
We rented an
apartment for a year,
and we only moved
with the necessities,
and that's when we realized
that, wow, living with less
is awesome.
You actually have more
time on your hands
to do the things
that you enjoy doing.
And so then from there,
it kind of led us
to really adopting
voluntary simplicity.
My husband was more stuck
on certain things than I am.
He said because
he's sentimental.
I think just he's macho.
I think that he was
hanging onto certain toys
because he felt like it made
him a man, extra, like a kayak,
golf clubs that he barely used.
But then as we
started really seeing
the great positive advantages or
effects of living simply, then
to me, you kind of
become addicted to it.
You kind of let go and
you feel so much better.
And then you let go more
and then you're like, gosh,
this is awesome.
It feels so much lighter.
I love the fact that
today, my whole wardrobe
fits in a carry-on.
That means that when
I want to go away
for the weekend or a month
or a week, all we have to do
is-- all of us, the four of
us, wardrobes fit in carry-ons.
So when we want to
go away, we just
throw our wardrobes in a
carry-on and we zip it,
we're out the door.
A cleaning service
comes, cleans the house,
and then we have renters
that come and basically
pay for our vacations.
When I pack for a trip, I
no longer have to wonder,
what should I take?
I'm going to Brazil,
I'm going to Europe,
I'm going to Iceland
or Patagonia, all
of different kind of climates.
I don't have to worry
anymore about what to pack.
about losing my luggage.
I don't have to go in the
check-in lines anymore.
There is a bunch of
things that somehow when
you start simplifying your life,
you start seeing the advantages
and you're like,
I can't go back.
I don't want more stuff.
I want even less.
And today, I'll wake up with a
smile on my face every morning
not because I generated just
a quart size of waste per year
for my family of four, I wake
up with a smile on my face
because living simply rocks.
It just has turned
our life around
to a life based on
experiences instead of stuff,
and that's what it is.
And living in those experiences
has brought our family closer.
I just could not envision going
back to the way I used to live.
So I think if you just
start decluttering, then
once you feel how much
better you feel, then
it pushes you to go further.
BETTINA LIMACO: And I
sort of second that.
I think it's a tough question.
I also started the
shop from a sabbatical.
We traveled for a year,
actually Green11 11
started from us seeing very
massive amounts of plastic
on the shores of Mount
Sinai in Egypt, actually,
and that's when we started the
business, is when we returned.
But I think it's
definitely starting slowly.
I don't think you have to
feel guilty about anything,
but it's really asking
yourself, do I really
need five bottles of
shampoo in my shower?
Do I really need
another necklace,
or do I really need
another pair of shoes?
I think it's starting
slowly and it's
starting with immediate
things, like do you really
need to buy that, is a way to--
BEA JOHNSON: And
something you can do
is if there is
something you feel
you want, then put it on a list
and don't buy it right away.
I think that's
kind of the problem
with our immediate
consumption in the US,
is that we want something and
it's just too easy, almost,
to grab it and get it.
If you put it on the list
and let that want work on you
and see if you truly want it
still at the end of the month.
I have found that when
I had a list like that,
by the end of the
month, I either
realized that I had another
item that could do the same job
or that I simply don't want it.
And then once I connected that
whatever-- if I spent money
on that, that meant
that I couldn't
spend my money on an activity or
doing something with my family.
Then it kind of
changed things around,
and today, I don't even
have one of those lists
any more because I don't
buy anything any more.
I haven't bought any new
clothes in like three years,
and it's not that I
don't-- I'm saying new.
I buy second-hand.
BETTINA LIMACO: That's
true, that's a good point.
BEA JOHNSON: I shop twice
a year for clothing.
I go mid-April and
mid-October, but it's
good to actually control
yourself, give yourself
some limits that way because
then that really helps
because I used to shop
even if I shop second-hand,
I would go whenever I
felt I wanted something.
But then you see something else
and you'll buy something else.
Especially we as women are
gatherers, men are hunters.
When they go shopping, they go
for one thing, they come home.
Women are gatherers.
If they go for
something, along the way
they're going to
pick a few things
and they come back with
a car full of stuff.
I used to go to
Target in my old life.
Every week somehow, I was led
to Target, and I would come out,
I would spend $100
on god knows what.
I have no idea today what
I was spending my money on.
Obviously not important
stuff because I
don't go to Target any more.
But anyway, so I
think giving yourself
limits like that really helps.
So when I go shop for my
wardrobe twice a year,
so I go mid-April
and mid-October
because it's the
beginning of two seasons,
then I know exactly what I want.
I just replace what
needs to be replaced,
so what I grew tired of--
generally color or patterns,
and then I stick with my
list and I just love the fact
that it doesn't cost me
much, it's off in a carry-on,
and really it makes
you feel free.
It's a weight off
your shoulders.
JAMIE: So can I ask one
more tactical question?
I'm really interested in
the tactical side of this
because I feel it's something
I think about a lot,
but then there's all these
hidden wasteful things
like packaging, for instance.
Packaging is so wasteful.
Think about buying toilet
paper in bulk, right?
It comes in a
little shrink wrap.
Sometimes it comes
individually wrapped.
Something like packaging,
how can we avoid packaging?
I know buying in
bulk, that's easy,
but I feel like
you have to be very
strategic about the places you
go and the things that you do
and what about buying, I don't
know, headphones or something
and it comes in that
huge plastic thing?
Can you talk about ways to avoid
packaging but still getting
some of the things we want?
BETTINA LIMACO: I
think buying off
Craigslist is a one, buying
used instead of buying new is
one avenue of getting rid of--
BEA JOHNSON: Yeah, that's
all my family does.
If you're looking for
something super specific
that you're not going to
find at a thrift store,
then we fall back on eBay.
And when we shop on eBay,
we select the option
in the left-hand
column that says
second-hand or
used or pre-owned,
and that's all we're all seeing.
It gives you quite
a bit of choice.
Believe me, there is everything.
I even buy my matches on eBay.
I don't buy new matches,
I buy second-hand matches.
They are vintage and
they're really pretty.
But so you can
literally find anything.
So when there is something super
specific like that that I need
and that I know I won't
find in a thrift store,
then I fall back on eBay.
I check that option and
then when I sent out to me,
I make sure that they send it
to me in paper or cardboard.
And then if it's a
bigger item, I also
obviously look on Craigslist
for something more local.
I wanted to also add a
little bit to your question
earlier, especially,
well, for clothing,
there is a couple of things.
Number one is in a regular
closet, in a regular closet,
people only use 20%
of their clothes.
The other 80%, people
hang onto for the what if.
What if I gain weight?
What if I lose weight?
What if I have a
wedding to go to?
What if I have this event?
What if I miss it?
It's been given to me, what if
I feel guilty if I donate it?
But the thing is, you
know exactly what the 20%
are because they're the clothes
that you keep on picking.
They're the clothes that
you keep on washing.
They're on top of the pile.
They're in the
front of your closet
because they're the ones that
you feel most comfortable in
and keep on wearing.
When you let go
of something, you
have to understand that you
are helping the environment.
A lot of people don't
really see that link,
but every time that
you donate something,
you're putting a very valuable
resource back on the market.
You're making it available
for someone else that either
needs it or is looking
for that thing,
and then they can buy it
secondhand, such as my family.
So if you guys have
a pair of sneakers,
Adidas size 9 and
1/2, please donate it
because those are
really hard to find.
But every time you
donate something,
you're putting it
back on the market
to make it available to
someone and you're boosting
the second-hand market.
The second-hand
market is extremely
important for the
future of zero waste,
so please let go of the
things you're not truly using.
JEFF CARLONI: Go ahead.
MICHAEL O'HEANEY:
Just one thing--
packaging is a huge
pain point for people.
People hate packaging.
They love to hate packaging.
I have a nine-year-old daughter,
and birthdays and holidays
are just the worst because
you open a couple of presents
and you're left with this
pile of plastic and paper
and cardboard and all
of this awful stuff.
There's a ton of stuff you can
do to sort of avoid packaging.
So it's buying in bulk,
it's buying and reuse.
BEA JOHNSON: Giving the gift of
experiences instead of stuff.
MICHAEL O'HEANEY: Giving
the gift of experiences
instead of stuff.
There's all these
kinds of things.
I think one of the things around
packaging that's important,
though, is also to communicate
to the companies that
are creating the packaging that
you don't like their packaging.
And so in Europe,
for instance, there's
a packaging directive
basically where
companies have to
take responsibility
for their packaging.
There's a fee attached to the
packaging that they create,
and there's basically take
back that's required of them,
so they're paying for it.
In creating a
financial disincentive
to create a lot of
packaging, companies
to figure out how to make
less packaging, how to
make things more efficient.
Walmart, a company
I'm not a huge fan of,
has done amazing things
to reduce packaging
and to shape packages
in certain ways
so that they can move
more efficiently more
of their stuff.
This can be done.
This is not some sort
of rocket science.
Things don't have to be
triple-wrapped in plastic
to get safely to you.
But taking that step,
avoiding plastic is important
and I think it does in some
ways send a market signal
to companies that you don't want
to buy their plastic schlock.
But communicating
that to the companies
is also very important.
So joining organizations
that are thinking about it,
supporting organizations
that are doing interesting
work around packaging.
There are some really
great innovative-- Product
Policy Institute, series
of great organizations
that are doing work
to reduce packaging
to reduce the impact
on transportation costs
and energy use, all of
those kinds of things.
BEA JOHNSON: It's the
power of the voice,
and I mentioned that earlier.
If you're not happy
with the packaging,
you feel you're forced to
buy a product that either you
don't like or you don't
like the packaging,
then let your voice be heard
because if you don't say
anything, nothing will change.
If you send the
packaging back to them
and propose alternatives, then
you're actually making things
happen and change will happen.
MICHAEL O'HEANEY:
Take a picture of it
and put it on social
media and tag the company.
BEA JOHNSON: That
is super powerful.
JEFF CARLONI: I
was going to say,
I heard of a story, our
neighbor company here,
Intuit, someone asked for
a CD to be sent to them
and they sent it in a huge box
with all this plastic wrap.
So the guy made a
YouTube video of, like,
titled, "Does Intuit
Hate the Environment?"
and it got all these
hits and that caught
the eye of the sustainability
person at Intuit
and they changed their
whole packaging process.
Now they just send it in a
paper sleeve and that's it,
and so it can work.
That was my
experience with that.
BEA JOHNSON: I really
believe that when
I started doing
waste-free living,
my husband said, you know,
what you're doing really
doesn't matter, it's really
the big corporations out there
that matter.
And I said, I don't agree.
I believe that we
as the consumer
are leading the manufacturing
world because the manufacturers
only make what we're
buying, so if we buy crap,
they'll make more crap.
If we buy packaging,
they'll make more packaging.
If we buy in bulk, then
we're supporting sustainable
practices and we're
literally voting
with our money for more bulk
alternatives to be out there.
So I think it's important to
realize the power of our money,
and every time we buy
something, it's a way to vote.
And if we buy right, then we're
basically spending our money
or investing our money into
a more sustainable future.
JEFF CARLONI: Thank you.
Kind of shifting gears
here a little bit.
Being that California's
in a drought,
this goes to I guess any of
you that want to answer this,
is there a direct
connection that you
can make between reducing waste
and saving water and helping
out with the drought?
MICHAEL O'HEANEY: So there's
some very direct ways.
We're working on a
campaign right now
around water bottling
in California.
Nestle Waters, which is the
world's largest distributor
of bottled water, we're
working on a campaign-- they're
taking water from a spring,
their Arrowhead brand-- well,
they say it's a spring; we
think it's ground water, which
is actually an important
distinction-- but in the San
Bernardino National Forest.
And I was saying
earlier before I
came in, I got an email from
the head of Nestle Waters North
America apologizing
because we've
been sort of going to town
the last couple of weeks
on a quote.
He during a radio
interview was asked
if Californians
are asking everyone
to sacrifice and to
sort of take less water,
would you consider
taking less water?
And he said, no, as a matter
of fact, if I could take more,
I would.
So that's a very direct
case, but water use
really around
bottled water is not
just the water that's
in it, but the water
it takes to produce the
plastics, the water that
takes-- the
manufacturing processes.
Agriculture in California
is really where it's at.
But I think there are ways
in living a simpler life
and reducing your overall impact
that you can have an impact.
I'm floored at some
level by the fact
that Californians
over the last year
have reduced their household
water use by 30%, 40%.
When the governor called
and the water boards
and local officials
called and said,
we need people to stop using
so much water, people did it.
People responded.
It's amazing.
I live in Berkeley.
It's amazing to
me to drive around
and the lawns are all brown.
It blows my mind.
So I think there's this
idea that living a simpler
life, that not partaking
in some of these kinds
of ridiculous products is
somehow a fringe or a weird way
to live or that I'm the only
one who thinks like this
and that no one else thinks
like this, when in truth, I
think most Americans
share a core set
of environmental values and when
asked, when really challenged
to step up, people do.
BETTINA LIMACO: Just to
add to the recycling piece,
I think a lot of people think
that when you throw something
in blue bin, something
like only 20% of plastics
actually get upcycled
because there's barely
any-- think about what
plastic can become.
It can only become,
like, bumpers
that you see for parking
or plastic t-shirts.
And the amount of water it
takes to produce something out
of plastic and to upcycle
something is enormous,
and all it does is delay the
entrance into the landfill.
So it eventually
all ends up there.
So once you're tired of
that plastic t-shirt,
once you're tried of
that plastic anything,
it ends up in the
landfill, as well.
JEFF CARLONI: Yeah, that
was kind of my next question
is that I think a lot of people,
especially here at Google,
we have everything is
recyclable and compostable.
There's very little
actual things
that are procured by
Google that are actually
able "landfill waste,"
so I think people
have kind of a misconception.
That's fine, we can
consume as much of this
as we want because it's going
to keep coming back forever.
But to your point, I think it's
something like only 16% or 17%
more efficient use of resources
than making a virgin product.
So all the
transportation and labor
and like all those
inputs you said still
have a great impact
on the environment.
Yeah, that's a great point.
BEA JOHNSON: And also we've
been told by the marketers
that buying packaging
or convenience
products saves time.
My lifestyle saves me way more
time than my old lifestyle
because, for example, today
I've adopted products that
are unpackaged, but
they're also less toxic
and they're multi-functional.
So for example, to wash
ourselves from like head
to toe, to wash our
hair, our face, our body,
and also to shave, we
use one bar of soap
that we buy loose from the
health food store unpackaged.
It costs us $2 for that bar.
That bar has eliminated
four other toxic products.
I no longer have to go to the
store to buy those things.
I no longer have to
put them in my car,
take them up 36
steps to my landing,
store them, and then
use them, but also
then take all the containers
back down to the curb,
and then go to the
store to buy more.
And that's one example,
and I have like 100 others.
We no longer buy paper towels,
plastic wrap, aluminum foil,
sandwich baggies,
freezer bags, trash bags.
All that stuff are
things that I used
to spend my money on going
to the store and buying.
It's actually once you realize
how much time-consuming it is
and you eliminate it from
your life, you're like,
damn, I'm never
going back to that.
We've been, again, led to
think that it saves time,
but it really doesn't.
JEFF CARLONI: Thank you.
This question's actually
for you, too, Bea.
I know you recently gave a
talk at Burning Man, right?
BEA JOHNSON: Yes, two.
Actually two.
JEFF CARLONI: So Burning
Man, for those of you--
does everyone know
what Burning Man is?
Do I have to explain that?
OK, so Burning Man is a
festival out in the desert.
Basically they have this
mantra, "Leave no trace."
They go out there,
they build this city,
and then when they
take the city down,
there's not a single strand
of anything left behind.
So being that you were there,
that was your first time there,
right?
BEA JOHNSON: Yeah,
I was a virgin.
JEFF CARLONI: Yeah,
you were a virgin.
How did that experience--
you were already
a person of zero waste, so how
did that experience of leave
no trace, radical self-reliance,
MOOP patrol, all that stuff,
how did that change
your perspective?
BEA JOHNSON: So doing zero
waste there for me was easy
because I already do
backpacking with no waste,
I buy food in bulk--
that is, dehydrated,
such as soup mixes and
lentil soup, pea soup, things
like that, or oatmeal, that
we can then add with hot water
and get a meal going.
And I also brought 20--
I refilled, I should say,
20 glass bottles of lemonade.
They don't really like you
to bring glass at Burning Man
because if you break it,
then it's really hard
to remove from the ground.
But I kept it within my tent, so
I knew that if something broke,
then I could sweep
it and take it home.
But I really love the leave no
trace principle of Burning Man.
It's made me much more
aware of my impact.
When you pack your tent, you're
supposed to really fine-comb
your area and they
also, of course,
encourage you to do the
common areas, which I did.
But when I
fine-combed my area, I
was just amazed
to see that I had
brought in dog hair, pine
needles, and feathers.
The dog hair and
the pine needles
were from previous
camp trips that I
had taken with that tent.
I didn't lose much of my
hair because it was literally
stuck to my head between
the dust of the Playa
and the oils of my head,
it was one big mess.
Nothing fell out of it.
I only found a couple,
but also the feathers
out of my down sleeping bag.
I had never really
thought of those things.
To me, they were insignificant
when I had camped before,
but there in the Playa, they
just really seemed out of place
and I really enjoyed
picking them up.
It was almost a spiritual
thing, and it really
made me aware of my impact
and I felt definitely
it was a definite step further
from the little picking I've
done before.
It made me feel more connected
also with my environment.
JEFF CARLONI: Great.
Do they have you
go to Burning Man?
I'm looking at you, Andreas.
Cool.
BEA JOHNSON: I
didn't see you there.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, where
were you, [INAUDIBLE]?
BEA JOHNSON: At Earth Gardens.
JEFF CARLONI: Earth Gardens?
BEA JOHNSON: And Center Camp.
JEFF CARLONI: Center Camp?
MALE SPEAKER: So I really
liked the positive example
you have of this pristine
home and everything's
so organized because I know
when I accumulate stuff,
it almost stresses
me out knowing it's
very hard to find something.
BEA JOHNSON: But what
you don't have does not
need to be organized,
maintained, stored.
MALE SPEAKER: I have a
lot of stuff I don't need.
I was wondering if
on company levels,
if you guys have
given lots of talks?
And I feel like Google
we do some stuff
well, some stuff not
so well, but is it
possible at company
levels you've
seen anything really outstanding
that you can kind of bring
along and present that an
entire company might want
to adopt because--
and maybe if that kind
of company-level action
filters down to the employees
and they're like, oh,
wow, I should do this
at home, as well.
BEA JOHNSON: So my job
is to go to companies
and talk about my
zero waste lifestyle
to inspire the employees
to adopt some of the things
we do at home.
But interestingly enough,
large corporations
are seeing this huge zero
waste movement taking
a lot of weight, and
I can't mention names,
but very large
manufacturers have
contacted me to get my
input on the products
that they have so that
they can make them better.
But I also want to be able
to put products out there
to attract the zero wasters.
So whether it be
the jars that I use
to purchase my wet food or
the cloth bags that I have,
or even just in the things
that we need in my home,
I think it's really
exciting to see
that this movement is growing
so much that these corporations
are noticing.
And the zero waste
lifestyle is just
in line with plastic-free
living, with tiny living,
with collaborative consumption.
We're all talking
about the same thing,
and actually even I read
that GE even themselves
have noticed the
interest for tiny living
and they are looking to adapt
their products to tiny living
so they can get then those
consumers for themselves.
But I'm sure you
see it probably?
MICHAEL O'HEANEY: There's
a ton of companies
doing interesting stuff,
both sort of on the consumer
side, the sort of
consumer-facing side, the way
that they're actually
dealing with the impact
of their products.
So probably not
surprisingly, Patagonia
is a real leader in this area.
They launched a program I
think two years ago now, maybe
three years ago,
called Common Threads,
which is basically they'll
take back their clothing
and recycle the clothing.
incredible repair business.
If you go to Patagonia's
YouTube channel,
they have some great
videos that are
these moving, incredible
videos about this guy who's
had this anorak for the last
20 years and sent it back
and Patagonia repairs
it and gives it
another couple of years of
life, or that kind of thing.
So in the
consumer-facing side, I
think there are a
lot of companies
doing interesting things around
repair, around take back.
The electronics
industry has done
an enormous amount in the last
10 years around take back.
Still a long ways to go.
There's interesting
folks like iFixit
that is actually basically doing
repair manuals for electronics
so that you can
crack open your phone
or whatever it is and
figure out how to fix it
instead of dumping it.
So there's sort of a lot of
interesting consumer-facing
stuff.
There's great companies
who are figuring out
new ways to do things.
So like the reason we
use carpet squares now
is this guy, Ray Anderson,
who founded a company called
Interface Carpet and he
figured out a less toxic way
to create carpets, and we use
squares because then you only
have to replace a square
when it gets worn instead
of the whole carpet.
And then just in terms of
campus life for big companies,
the fact that there is a
compost bin in this room to me
is remarkable.
Food waste is a huge
part of municipal waste,
and not a lot of
folks are set up
to actually do that kind
of waste collection,
so I think that's
important, as well.
So I think companies
aren't doing
as much as I'd like
them to do, but there
are a lot of great
companies who are looking
at how to create better
products for their consumers,
how to create a better
life for their employees.
We're working with-- again,
not a big surprise company--
we're working with Ben
and Jerry's right now.
All of their scoopers,
the scoop shop employees,
are taking an online
boot camp we have
around community involvement.
They put a sort of big emphasis
on their employees being
engaged in their
communities, so they
are trying to do that,
which one of the reasons
I mention community,
community is
kind of the antidote to stuff.
So we were talking earlier--
stuff swaps, finding places,
building, sharing communities.
Berkeley, we have a
tool-lending library
that's part of
the public library
system, which is incredible.
I don't need all of
these things for myself.
I rented a dolly,
like a hand cart.
I only need that
maybe once a year.
Why do I need my own,
and probably not everyone
on my block needs their own.
I can go to the library with
my library card, get a dolly,
I can get a jack hammer,
I can get garden tools,
you can get hammers
and screwdrivers
and all the kinds of things
that you would possibly need.
Instead of going to Home
Depot, I go to the library.
So communities,
businesses are all
doing super interesting
things, I think.
BEA JOHNSON: And there
is a lot to learn, also,
from other countries.
Last year when I
went to Brazil, I
was invited to talk about
my lifestyle over there
as the way of the future.
Interestingly
enough, I was given
a tour of a grocery
that does zero waste.
Now, when I entered
that store, I
thought, oh, well, I can
do zero waste in that store
because everything was packaged.
And I showed up
with my cloth bag
and I asked if they would put a
pastry in my little cloth bag.
And he said, well, because it's
you, they will, but otherwise,
they wouldn't.
And I'm like, OK,
well, that's a shame.
But on the other side,
in the back of the store,
these guys used to
pay huge tipping fees
for logging all the packaging
from their supply chain
to landfill, but they figure now
that those materials actually
could be a good
source of profit.
So they found a
way of separating
all their different
materials and then were
matched with recyclers that
then buy those materials.
They even had a guy in that
grocery store whose job,
the staff, whose job
it was to separate
the food from the
packaging, the food
that they were not able
to donate to a food bank.
His job was to separate
the food from the packaging
so then they were able
to compost that food,
and then they turned around and
they were selling the compost
at the grocery store.
So this was an
amazing example to me.
Over there in Brazil where you
think, we're leading all this
and we'll show the world.
But no, there are amazing things
that are being done everywhere,
and those guys realize
that now actually it
saved them a bunch of money, but
they're also even making money
from their waste material.
MICHAEL O'HEANEY:
If you're looking
for a little inspiration, like
this afternoon when you're back
at your desk and you
want check out a video,
look at the
Biomimicry Institute.
You all know what biomimicry is?
It's basically designers
mimicking natural processes,
and so it's things
like figuring out
less toxic ways
to make black dye,
or how to create fans that
use less energy basically
by studying how nature
does these things.
And they have these
just incredible stories
of companies who figured out
more efficient, less waste,
less resources wasted in
the production of products
and in the way they make things.
Biomimicry-- it's a
great site and they
have some really great examples
of things companies are doing.
JEFF CARLONI: Thank you guys.
Unfortunately, we're
about out of time,
but we could do this all day.
[INAUDIBLE] after
this, but thank
you so much for coming and
spending your time with us.
Thank you guys all for coming.
I appreciate it.
If you want to stick around
and ask questions after,
feel free to do that.
Just a couple things
I'll encourage you
do after this event
to learn more.
Go to storyofstuff.org,
watch the videos.
Check out Bea's book, of course.
If you live in the city,
shop at Bettina's store.
Those are some easy ways to
reduce your waste stream right
there.
Here on campus, carry your
reusable mugs everywhere
you go, your personal
water bottles.
Don't get to-go boxes.
Again, we vote with our choices,
even when it's free, right?
So just those are some simple
things you can do here.
BEA JOHNSON: Thank you.
MICHAEL O'HEANEY: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]